Mong qua 1 người tháng 7 năm, anh y hủ chăm 8 năm, tại công ty chất giảm giữ hạn sản phẩm thị thao bay xem,
xa tu vũ, tình phút thọc, xây ra vụ tên hạn nào đầu khiến 2 người thương vòng.
Thế bào cao của công ty và kết quả sắp mình của đàn công tác xa tu vũ,
sau định nghe 1 người tháng 7, có một đơn vị vẫn chuyển thiết đi,
may móc đến rau cho công ty bay xem.
Đơn vị vẫn chuyển có nhiều 2 người dân ở chiến địa bản xa đe dễ thỗ trợ tháng giữa,
đưa may móc xuống, khoa chiến đưa may móc xuống vất người bị chượt,
giữ hỏi đẹp vào 2 người bị thương nha. Ngay sâu đó,
cả 2 được đưa đi cấp dưới như 1 người khu qua khỏi,
còn 1 người bị cái thay, đã được đưa đi bình tình viết đất,
hà nội, đưa đuí dịch.
Sau khi sự việc xây ra, công ty bay xem trước mắt đã hỗ trợ ra định có người thủ vong năm
chượt đồng, người bị thương 2 chượt đồng.
Có đơn vị vẫn chuyển thiết bị chức mắt hỗ trợ ra định có người thủ vong 2 mi trợ đồng.
Chính quyền đứa phương cũng đã bảo cao lên ui bán nhân dân và công an tình,
đồng thời đi tham hỏi đồng viên ra định nạn nhân.